vous loupez votre trajectoire à l'écran
vous faites reset vous la loupez sur la
piste vous pouvez mourir
Yann tu passes ton temps sur tes jeux
vidéo à rêver de course de voiture papa
tu nous dis toujours qu'on doit faire ce
qu'on aime
tu sais ce que ça coûte ces voitures
ouvre les yeux
c'est pas notre monde mon fils
c'est quoi un concours
les meilleurs joueurs de Gran Turismo du
monde
une chance de courir en professionnel tu
es en train de me dire que tu vas
recruter un gamin qui joue à des jeux
vidéo dans sa chambre pour le sanglier à
bord d'un Scud qui monte à plus de 300 à
l'heure
il va se faire massacrer à qui pourquoi
les pilotes sont des vrais athlètes des
petits jeunes sont des gamers
pendant la course la température dans le
cockpit grimpe à 60°c
tu as un bonus pour ça dans tes jeux
ça reste de la folie mais de tous les
geeks de canapé que tu m'as envoyé c'est
le meilleur tu es pris
bienvenue dans la team Nissan c'est quoi
la suite bah c'est trop
les autres pilotes vont pas te faire de
cadeaux
on appelle ça piloter
votre trajectoire à l'écran vous faites
reset vous la loupez sur la piste
vous pouvez mourir
je connais circuit j'ai couru dessus
mille fois
et un champion